meet their bas newest full-time resident
a four-star W that will stay open when
most of the town shuts down designers
altered the slope so guests can ski
right to the front door
bubble chairs for cocktails at sunset a
spa for partners who don't ski
those chalets behind me don't look like
a typical W they've had to modify their
design to fit the Alpine profile it's a
test of whether or not their brand of
urban luxury can survive at altitude
apres ski begins on the mountain at the
hotel's bar under snow and stone there's
an underground nightclub a bunker that
keeps its secrets buried
what do you need to do to make this bar
the spot in their head you need the
amazing music which we have we have
three and house digits that are really
amazing and then the atmosphere but
again I think we have that design of the
bar is great it's completely new for
Verbier it's much more international
than what you could find in Libya right
now a hundred and thirty rooms and
suites that starts around five hundred
dollars and climbed with each floor
balconies and fireplaces in every room
but the challenge will be to fill them
in Verbier x' sunnier and slushy ER
months there's money in the convention
set as well as the Jet Set W is betting
that this conference space which has a
capacity of 300 making it the largest in
this region of Switzerland will help
sustain it in the offseason with the
event business when the rest of their ba
empties out it's a gamble that a
full-service hotel can thrive in a
part-time town this will allow us to
attract out of business than what we are
used to in there B we have specialists
in seal specialists in every sector
whether it's the automobile or
pharmaceutical or sports these people
will get their business to this hotel
and just as every ski town relies on the
snow guards this W will need some help
it's a challenge I'm not worried but
it's a challenge it will take a lot of
work a lot of energy and some luck you
always need a bit love lucky in life
hospitality and occupancy in a mountain
resort when the snow melts hot snickles
bloomberg Verbier
you